hey everyone steve lantro with collider
and i am thrilled to be talking to the
filmmakers behind dungeons and dragons
gentlemen you guys know i'm a big fan of
all of your work and i think the the
footage the trailer i don't i don't
think was it it was the trailer yeah the
the trailer looks
really really fun and i think like is
that the movie is it just like a really
fun ride it is absolutely a ride if
rides also made you cry because
there's some of that there's some of
that too yeah no it's you know what we
tried to capture the spirit of what it
is to play a d d game which is life and
death stakes one minute and then you're
laughing your heads off the next and
that's what this movie hopefully is
and to me like it all comes down to tone
right and i think the tone that you want
to hit is that thing where you're just
like you're having this fun fun fun time
and you're getting hit in the heart all
the time over and over again and you see
stuff you've never seen before and
that's what these guys do so well i mean
it goes back to me having worked with
them on spider-man homecoming and and
reading the first thing i ever read of
theirs was just this thing that kind of
matched up genres and was hilarious and
heartfelt and adventurous and everything
else and knowing that they had that in
them and and being so thankful to be on
this journey with them here to bring
this totally huge new world to life it's
like it's it's damn exciting so i mean i
hypothetically have heard you've test
screened the movie hypothetically what
did you learn i think you have uh what
did you learn from those screenings
where are you in the editing room uh
we're basically locked in terms of the
edit we still have you know a lot of vfx
work coming in a lot of music that we
need to conform and stuff but uh beyond
that i think the thing that we learned
the most from our test screenings was
that it it really appealed not just to
dnd fans people that had no idea what
they were watching when they were going
into the test screening actually were
engaged and and they didn't think that
they would be because it's a d movie and
it's got us
not necessarily a stigma but it has a
lot of baggage attached to it in terms
of like what people expect out of it and
i think that was like a pleasant
surprise for a lot of people
uh yeah and and i mean especially
women are loving it too which you know d
d is not necessarily thought of as but
in fact it is and i think if handled
right it it should be because it's all
about characters it's all about the
people feeling real and relatable we
tried to tell the story of some people
who are not superheroes by any means
they kind of suck at a lot of things but
they're great at other things and so how
do you make those skills come to the
fore how do you tell a story where they
all get to kind of level up over the
movie i saw someone on twitter say this
and i was thinking the same thing
looking at the footage it almost looks
like like i don't wanna like the
guardians of the galaxy meets d and d in
terms of like the fun characters is that
accurate or is that that's the producer
i mean look to me the thing the thing
about these kind of movies is
i
i come from like a background where like
i've worked at marvel for a really long
time but i didn't grow up inherently as
like the biggest fan of all that marvel
stuff and one of the things that i think
i was particularly good at in that era
of my life was going how do we make this
thing that could be really nerdy and
like really like like just for this one
particular audience something that
everyone can kind of relate to and that
was kind of the challenge with guardians
was like space movies like make a space
movie that like my grandmother can love
and and i think here it's like make a
fantasy movie that my grandmother can
love but also make it so that the
fantasy people love the fantasy movie
and it's it's it's that like walking
that line and threading that needle i
think that's what james again did really
successfully with guardians and i think
that's what we're hopefully i really
feel like we're trying to do here is
like walk that line yeah and make it so
it's 100 serious 100 has real stakes and
real you know emotion but also that
you're having a damn good time we'll
know more when we screen it for his
grandmother it's coming up
[Laughter]
so obviously any dungeons and dragons
movie has dragons and i'm very curious
uh are there multiple dragons what can
you say about how many dragons are in
the movie i can say that there are
multiple dragons in the movie i can't
say specifically who or what they are uh
but they are very unique in their own
way and there are depictions of these
dragons that have not been seen before
on screen i can say that i think talk a
little bit about designing the dragons
because that's another that's a huge
thing and obviously there's many
versions if you look at any d d cover
you can see all these different dragons
how much did you look at that material
and say we have to give the fans of d d
something that looks like that and how
much we sort of like we just have to do
the dragons that's best for the movie
that what you just said right it was
like subverting people's expectations to
a certain degree of like things that
they haven't seen in in dragons but also
giving them like a more traditional look
at like the dragons that
is from you know their their fantasy
books so it's it's finding that balance
and that's sort of typical of how we
approached every aspect of this movie
because there's a lot of lore there's a
lot of things that sort of you know you
expect it to be um and we work closely
with the wizards of the coast to make
sure that we were kind of within the
right zone of what it needed to be for
the fans to appreciate it and and not be
thrown by it but ultimately we also had
to make it our own and make it work for
this movie and so you know yeah and that
was one of the things i think like we
worked really closely with this uh uh
art director super senior guy at watsi
named jeremy jarvis and his thing was
always like it's not about accuracy it's
about authenticity and it was like about
capturing the vibe of say a specific
kind of dragon and capturing what makes
those dragons tick for fans and for the
lore
and but also understanding that like
it's a campaign everything is different
every time you stumble into a different
you know dragon's den it's gonna be a
little bit different than the last time
and and it can be different it can be
unexpected and so finding a way to walk
that line and i think we had really
incredible artists working and we had
really incredible support from watsi and
i think that together with a great
script that called for specific needs
for the dragons made it like kind of
unique and and kind of special
uh you guys obviously settled on a title
was it almost something else how close
did was it almost guns and dragons
without you know honor like how did you
decide on it yeah i mean it was a long
it was a long process uh deciding on
that because you know it's it's
representative of this much bigger you
know brand and i think that was that was
what the kind of challenge was was how
are we going to depict this movie at
first when we wrote it we just called it
dungeons and dragons but um there was
rightfully like the concern that it
doesn't necessarily
uh emphasize the the scope of dungeons
and dragons the fact that dungeons and
dragons isn't just this story this is
just one of many stories that kind of
live in the world and that's kind of
where our title landed was it almost
something else it was almost a couple
things but it wasn't really because
no one really felt that they captured it
right like there's a moment in that
process when you're talking to marketing
you're talking to brand you're looking
at the screenplay you're looking at the
movie you're making and you go oh it
could be this and then no one's really
that excited about it titles thrown out
that felt more like marketing things
than the spirit of the movie
and then this kind of came along and we
were all like yeah that kind of captures
who these who this team is you know and
it kind of says something about this
movie in particular and not just like
generic generic and and so it's like
that that's the
line to walk there is to make sure you
find the thing that captures the soul of
the film and i think it does i think
it's a nice title it's a very true kind
of subtitle to what the movie is about
so i've been waiting for a kick-ass
dungeons and dragons movies since i was
a kid i'm going to be really honest
about this obviously the studio everyone
involved this is potentially a really
big franchise in a world that can be
explored when you guys were first
talking to the studio about doing this
and getting the green light how much are
they saying to you okay this is great
but we want to make sure you have like
three ideas for other things like how
much are they thinking about the world
and how much is it sort of like let's
just make this one movie there was no
pressure put on us to think in terms of
a cinematic universe um
we obviously wanted to create characters
and an environment that could grow and
that had the potential for more films
but that wasn't at all in the forefront
of our approach to this yeah and then by
the way that's a testament to the
studios because i think
sometimes the studios put the cart
before the horse and try to create these
cinematic unibor
universes before the first movie even
comes out and so i think they were smart
and savvy enough to know that the first
one's got to work before you even dive
into the others that said i think it's a
really good jumping off point for a lot
of other
potential movies that come after it i
mean having come like through the the
world that i grew up in and like it's
like we never thought about
sequels on that first round of movies
like it was just about make this movie
good make this movie good make this
movie good okay now we got to make
avengers movie that ties it all together
how do we do that oh my god and but the
the journey to that wasn't like we got
to start planning right it's it's it has
to be that you make something great in
its own merit and so i was really like
adamant like let's not be thinking ahead
whenever that would come up from you
know if someone would say something
about the future i'd be like
it's this this is the future this movie
being good is the future so i'm curious
what can you say about which characters
like character classes types
what can you reveal about what's in the
movie well we had to we we made sure
that we had as
much of a diverse kind of group of
characters in terms of their in terms of
their race and class and uh i think we
really covered as as many as we possibly
could without having even more
characters you know in our in our
ensembles so we have a we have a big
group of people they all kind of
represent a very specific thing that i
think a lot of players can sort of see
themselves in but also it's not so kind
of bogged down with the proper nouns
that people that aren't familiar with
the with the game are going to be
alienated you got led zeppelin in the uh
trailer
a how much did that cost
and b how much did that cost and c was
it always going to be led zeppelin was
this like the dream what happens if they
said no well that is a funny question we
can't not tell you how much it costs
because i'm not even quite sure i know
it was very complicated and it happened
at the very last minute um so we were
definitely on a high wire without a net
for a second um and i am so thankful
that they
saw it and uh and said yes because i
think it really is additive and cool and
kicks a lot of ass and i think it kind
of broadens things in a way that you're
like heck yeah you know and so it was it
was a it was definitely a complicated
process for the music i will say that um
when a studio is willing to spend what
it costs to get led zeppelin it's a good
sign for their faith in the movie
and zeppelin by the way is so perfect
for dungeons and dragons especially
since like zeppelin in its heyday was
when dungeons and dragons kind of came
to be so there is this real crossover
that i think is is juicy and still feels
kind of contemporary and different from
uh other fantasy fantasy films that
you'd see so it was kind of it it was a
perfect combination i think i'm very
thankful that they that they dove in
with us on this it's really it's really
cool oh i watched the trailer twice and
i'm like this
you should be thanking your marketing
team because it's a fantastic trailer
and the thing that people don't realize
is this early out you don't have a lot
of vfx shots to work with you know what
i mean or i guess you were finishing
shots for this trailer yeah we were
pushing very very much to get these done
i gotta stop i'm just gonna say
sincerely i really can't wait to see the
movie which i know will be finished
about march 1st
with with vfx but really it looks
fantastic and i wish you guys nothing
but the best and thank you so much for
coming through thank you thank you
you